we found hamed in an abandoned building
tending to his wounds the iranian
amputee says he crossed into greece
twice
since turkey opened its borders more
than a week ago
he returned with wounds all over
they caught me and beat me while they
took me to a car i begged them and said
i'm handicapped don't beat me leave me
alone but they wouldn't listen
on the second floor a temporary family
has formed
bound by trauma and desperation
once strangers now linked by the
solidarity
of feeling ostracized i am
we might have come from third world
countries but we're not third class
citizens
we also have the right to live and have
a future for our children
afghan refugee nasir has become a kind
of father
figure he and his wife crossed into
greece
three times twice by climbing through a
fence
and once on a fisherman's boat he says
greek soldiers stripped the men to their
underwear tasered them and when they
collapsed
beat them with sticks
the handcuffed men took us to the
riverbank and kicked us into the river
they said now leave some of us managed
to cross like a fish
some like a duck two of the friends
couldn't get out of the river
we told turkish fishermen that we left
two people behind
they went to search for our friends and
we never saw them again
the greek government has not responded
to the accusations
it has stopped accepting asylum
applications for one month
and pledged to expel those entering
illegally
nasir describes what's happening to
refugees and migrants who cross into
greece
as a horror movie yet he and hamed plan
to make another attempt clinging to the
possibility
like thousands others that the next time
will have a more humane ending
natasha ghanim al jazeera edurnae on the
turkey greece border